Now the ABO enzyme that can modify carbohydrates
on the surface of red blood cells is coded
in your genome, and it's just one example
of hundreds of thousands of different proteins in your
body that perform a specific function. After all,
proteins make the cell go round. For example, your
genome also codes for the enzyme lactase, which
is another protein that allows all infants to metabolize
milk from the mother. But over time, some people lose the expression of this
enzyme, or protein, and they can become
lactose intolerant. We'll learn more about that in
lesson four. Your genome also codes for
the enzyme tyrosinase. Which is a protein
that's the rate limiting for producing melanin,
the main pigment for skin pigmentation. Without tyrosinase,
an individual could present with albinism, because there
would be a lack of pigment in the
skin, hair, and eyes. We'll learn more about
this trait in lesson six. Your genum also
codes for protein called FGFR3 or fiberblast growth
factor receptor 3. Which can regulate bone growth
and controls the trait of achondroplasia, one of
the most common forms of dwarfism. An overactive version
of this protein, significantly reduces bone growth and results in dwarfism. And
as a last example, your genome also codes for a protein called BRCA1, or Breast
Cancer Type 1 Susceptibility Gene, which
repairs broken DNA strands. A non-functional version
of this protein significantly increases the risk
of breast cancer. Now, these are just
examples of different enzymes or proteins. We use the words interchangeably.
And the work of your genome is to have a cell
that uses its code to make all of these different proteins
or enzymes or products necessary to build your body and your traits.